It's not as helpful as you think it is.
Oh wonderful.
Do you remember when we played Brett and Fred and we were trying to use Discord voice and there was enough of a delay that it was still like fucking us up hard?
And then we actually had to use the in-game timer.
Yeah, we had to use the in-game timer because voice was just not working.
That's basically it.
That won't happen here.
This is a god game.
Alright, so Mint wants to spend like five hours in this game.
So...
You hate yourself that much, huh?
More than anyone else.
I mean, Mint, how many times have you played the first game?
I don't know.
Probably as many times as you.
And that's how much we love Pico Park.
That's how much we love it.
I love you guys so much I don't ever want to stop playing.
Oh my god, really?
Then let's play all the way to the end, guys.
Okay.
Yeah.
Let's go!
Guys, do you guys want to know how many worlds that is?
That's like ten.
I think that's more than ten actually.
Can I come to the game now?
Alright.
Yeah, I'm live now.
Oh, I'm streaming.
Hi!
Hello!
We're all streaming.
So...
Hello, everybody.
Welcome to Pico Park 2.
We all have foogies that tell us what color we are.
I'm yellow.
Guys, please, I can't move.
Yeah, you were on my head the entire time.
Guys!
It's Ridd, please!
Ridd, please!
Ridd!
Oh my gosh!
Is something happening?
Ridd's butt is on me!
What the fuck?
Please!
I can't move.
What if I switch between you guys?
Oh, that's good!
We can't die yet.
That's good.
Here we go.
Guys, I think we can...
I think we have to do it at the same time.
Wait, what?
Wait, why doesn't the spring jump?
Maybe we have to do it at the same time.
There's like one for each of us, so I feel like that has to be a mechanic.
Okay.
Surely.
Okay, why don't we all get off the spring, guys?
Why don't we all...
Guys, the spring's not working.
Why don't we all get off the spring, guys?
We have a method.
Okay, wait.
I think I know.
What if, like, I fall from here and then...
Okay, no, that doesn't work.
Wait, what?
Guys, I don't...
There's no way.
There's no way we're tall enough.
There's like eight of us.
Think it up.
What if someone jumps from the top person?
Oh, that's true!
We make a tower.
Oh.
Okay.
There's like a little diving board.
Alright, do we have a diving board?
Guys.
Guys, this is level one, guys.
Guys, this is level...
It's level one.
Okay, I'm stuck.
I'm up, I'm up.
Okay, what are we...
Okay, keep going up, guys.
Going up, going up.
Is it enough to get to the top?
No, I don't think so.
We got this.
We can make it.
We can make it if we try.
Wait.
Oh my god.
We did make it.
Press the button.
I can be here the whole...
Oh, it works now.
Now they're yelling at you.
Let's go.
We did have to stack.
I can't believe it was that easy.
You have to jump on the button every time.
Well, someone's tongue gets bumped.
You have to keep pushing it.
Oh, I see.
Alright.
Guys, I can't believe that was super simple.
That only took us way too long.
No, we have to stack up.
Yeah, guys.
Make an elevator.
I think it only does the other one, right?
Yeah, yeah.
We have to...
Nice.
I got the key.
Why is it counting down?
Is that a bad thing?
No, it gives you a countdown.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, yeah.
We have to...
We have to each...
We have to go to the top.
Alright.
You see the vision.
Oh, go, go, go.
Oh my god.
I don't think it works if there's people on top.
Yeah, there's people on top.
It doesn't work.
So we gotta...
I like my role of watching like a god.
Here we go.
Wee!
Oh, okay.
Nobody...
We have to wait for Red.
We have to...
We have to wait for Black to get to the other side.
Any day now.
Okay, okay, okay.
Now we keep doing it.
Alright, don't worry.
I'll be butt-impressing.
Alright, we got it.
Wee!
Alright.
My favorite bit of Peek-a-Pot.
I'll be the last one.
I can make it.
Don't worry.
Yay!
We did it!
Okay.
I got the key.
I don't think so.
We did it.
I blocked the door.
Can you imagine if someone fell right now?
Yeah, like, we're failing levels.
Level 1 off the bat.
So we're gonna skip world 7, right?
Yeah, 7-3.
Yeah, we're gonna make it to world 7-3 so easily.
It has to be 7 of us.
Okay.
Who's not pushing?
Who's not doing their part?
Do your part, guys!
We can't...
What?
Somebody died!
Okay, so, can we, like, bait that?
I'm gonna try baiting it.
Okay, you can't bait it.
Wait, oh!
Yeah, the box hit it.
So the box has to hit it first.
All we have to do is not walk to the left.
You mean the right?
I mean the right.
We'll see about that.
What's the other left?
We need everybody to do their part.
Push!
Okay, now go left.
Go left.
Push!
It's gonna hit you!
Any second now!
Get off the box!
I swear, I will...
I will go for it.
I will go for it if you do this.
I will go for it!
Are you for serious?
It's level 2!
It's level 1.
It's not even level 1.
Why are you pulling apart?
I'm fighting!
I'm trying to push.
Push!
He's trying to be a manager right now.
I'm not the one who died.
It was Doki.
Doki, come on.
Alright, let's go.
It's okay.
It's gonna hit that, right?
Oh, it's not?
What?
Oh, I know!
Something has to be underneath the box!
What if somebody was underneath the box and it hits the box itself?
That's a great idea.
Take one for the team, buddy.
Okay.
Yeah, they wear the box.
I can't hear you.
Wait, how do you wear it and people still push it?
You push the person.
Drop it on your head.
Okay, alright.
Come on!
Go, Lime!
Go!
Go, Snuffy!
Oh, it works!
She has the helmet!
We are shockingly intelligent.
Oh my god.
She has the bicycle helmet.
Follow me.
Alright, nice.
Stop!
We need to climb up!
We need to stack!
Stack, guys!
It's stacking time!
We're stacking?
Teamwork?
I'm pushing!
Guys!
The door!
Put it in!
We just have to put the key into the door.
The key goes into the door hole, guys.
What can you leave out?
We're doing great.
We're doing exactly how I thought it would go.
Yeah, we got this.
We're so good.
We might be gamers.
We might be gamers, guys.
Look at that.
This is how...
This is how we build friendship, everybody.
Oh!
What's this?
Keep hitting it!
Hit it!
Keep going!
Keep bashing your head at it!
Fix the problem!
Go!
I'm so smart.
Keep going!
We can't stop!
Nice!
Whoa!
You don't have to do it anymore.
I just wanted to...
I wanted to be part of it.
Yeah, that was easy.
Let's do it again.
We can't die in this fight.
You say that.
We'll find a way.
What if it collapses on top of us?
Alright.
We all got Brunt Force Trauma.
I feel like the skill jump is gonna hit us hard in level 2.
This seems too easy.
Okay.
What's going on?
As you said, the forms are moving.
Don't hit the jumpy jumps.
Don't jump.
Don't go over there.
You know you want to jump.
What if I go really fast?
There we go.
He just sees me as a stepping stool.
Yeah.
That is incredibly confusing.
I don't like the screen zooming out like that.
We each have to have a button.
Okay.
I got the left side.
I got this button.
The door opens there.
And then we have three more.
That little hole.
You see that little hole?
Just gotta climb it.
Yes!
Where's the last one?
Oh, the last one's over there.
To the left side.
And then...
Mint, this is your job.
Up to...
To knock guys?
Yeah.
Oh, wait.
Guys, I might need some help.
Go back on the button.
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
Oh, yeah.
I just went through.
Did you just abandon us?
No, it's okay, guys.
It's okay.
We're all okay now.
Wait, what the fuck is that?
What is that?
Is it this one?
Which one was it?
Oh, I got you.
I got you.
Who would have...
Who could have done such a thing?
Locked down in there.
Who would have done such a thing?
It's not a game.
Oh, wait.
Wait.
Can you get...
Okay, just jump over.
Who's that that's lost and stuck?
Okay, here.
Just jump like this.
Like that.
I think he probably just jumped.
Yeah.
He just jumped.
That scared me.
Oh, my god.
I'm scared.
Do you like the little projectile I made for you?
The analysis on how to jump?
Yes.
Just do that.
Come this way.
Sorry.
You should be sorry.
We have like a laser pointer for our cat.
A laser pointer to guide it.
Oh, my god.
Yay!
Wow!
I'm so proud of all of you guys.
Alright, let's show you guys how much we have.
We're still on pace.
Oh, there's a third page?
Oh, never mind.
There's a third page?
We should just do the last one.
Yeah, let's just do the last one.
Okay, let's see what it's like, guys.
Yeah, let's just see what it's like.
Yeah, let's see.
Oh, yeah.
That's not good,
is it?
Yes, come on!
Just go right!
Go, go, go, go!
No!
Okay, you guys are dead.
Well, maybe not everyone.
Guys, if we can...
It's always yellow.
What do you mean it's always yellow?
It's yellow!
What are you doing?
Oh, my God!
Hold down.
You need to walk in by pressing the key one time.
Wow, man!
What did I tell you?
I'm gonna get out of here.
Stop jumping over!
This is a pig issue!
I'm jumping over!
Watch out, watch out!
We were so close.
I just made that.
If it hadn't been for you...
You know what I'm talking about.
I got all the masks.
Oh, my bad.
Please!
I went backwards.
Guys, if we can beat level one...
Guys, if we can beat level one, if we can beat this level, we can beat all the other levels, guys.
That's so true.
I feel like the other level users have had us for this.
Yay!
Okay.
We have to stack to the side, guys.
We have to play the game.
Why aren't you moving?
I'm trying to.
We're okay, we're okay.
We have to stack.
The other person has to go to the left side.
The other person has to go to the left.
This is the worst level we ever have.
That's not even a chance.
Five in a row, huh?
Oh, my God.
It can't be that.
We're fine, we're fine, we're fine.
Oh, this way, this way, this way.
We figured it out.
We figured it out, though.
Oh, my God.
Nobody want a hair on this level.
There can't be any delay, guys.
There can't be any delay.
We have to...
We have to keep going.
We can't stop.
Yikes.
Literally, it cannot stop.
What are you doing?
I'm dying.
I'm at the end.
I'm not sure this kind of torture was depicted in the Bible.
Not in a good way.
I have to wait for you guys.
I have to...
I must imagine Cisabeth on the other side.
One must imagine Cisabeth at the other side.
OK, we can see this.
I believe.
Some of you guys have to go to the right side, so we need four people on the far right.
And then the rest of us at the bridge, the thing.
Okay, there we go, I guess that's us.
Oh, wow!
Okay!
Okay, okay, nice, nice.
Wait, wait, wait.
Come back.
Is the gear come back?
Okay, I guess.
Yeah, we're going.
Alright, we're fine.
Oh, it does, it does, okay.
I got you, little guy.
Stay there.
Guys, we made it.
We're doing it.
We're working together.
Okay, we're gonna be able to do that again.
Okay, that's two saws.
What are you doing, you fool?
Okay, we'll see what happens to her.
Okay, keep going forward.
Okay.
Okay, everything seems okay.
So far.
I think we're good.
No, I don't...
Wait, what do you mean by that?
Hey, hey.
What a doki hat.
No.
No, I don't deal with that.
I'm not.
This isn't for me.
Guys, we have to see what our death is like, guys.
Hold single file.
Hold your hand.
We have a buddy system.
We should get a buddy system right now.
Just in case.
Okay.
We need to see what's up ahead, Rin.
We need to know what's up ahead.
What lies ahead of us.
Oh, no.
Okay.
I have an idea.
Let's just get over here.
Let's just get right...
How does it go back down?
I think we have to stack here.
No, no.
We have to run.
We have to run and get to the safe point.
No, wait.
It's not going to go down once we have...
How do we get back down?
Okay, so there's nothing up there.
Well, we let the elevator go down and then maybe like...
The camera would have moved if that was something up there.
Oh, we can't.
Okay, I'm sensing maybe the saws will go at a different time or something.
Where's the door?
Is it back there?
Where was the door?
Yeah, the door is at the very beginning.
Oh, it is.
Oh, it was.
We send one lone soldier.
One brave skull.
Alright.
Green, you're closest.
Green is closest.
Juniper is closest.
And we'll inch across to see how much space we can get.
One brave soul.
You have to get over so we can see the key.
Okay, we gotta inch.
We gotta inch.
Okay, alright.
Oh god.
Okay.
Ready?
Guys.
We're
doing so good.
We found it.
I still don't really know how to do the thing.
I think it's one at a time.
Single file.
Yeah.
It was literally single file.
Which is what I was trying to say.
You need to like jump single file.
As little as possible.
Oh my god.
It feels like we're in kindergarten and Lime's the teacher.
Alright.
Mama.
Don't do that.
Please.
Oh my god.
Go ahead.
I don't piss myself.
That was almost impressive.
Alright.
I'll jump over you.
Any day now guys.
Any day now.
You're too slow.
Jump over you.
I'll do it.
Alright.
We got this.
Nice.
And then we can...
Your big head is in the way.
Nice.
Alright.
I'm okay.
Everything is fine.
See?
Alright.
And then...
The lone soul.
A single soldier.
Just me.
Alright.
Chungus World.
Okay.
We should all make like a single line.
No one on top of each other's head.
Let's do a test run.
Like imagine we have the key.
Sure.
Oh yes.
Yeah.
Alright.
I'm going to do it.
Okay.
I failed.
You gotta jump.
You gotta do this.
You have to jump.
You have to wait until it's at the very bottom to.
Wait.
Can you jump and then it goes down a little bit?
Is that?
Yeah.
Look at that!
We're ready!
We got this!
We have the mechanics now.
The first one also needs a couple of people.
Can this squish someone?
No, no.
You get to lose.
Sacrifice yourself to find out.
It's for science!
For science!
She just loves playing this game guys.
Are you ready?
I think we can see more.
Go!
Bring the key higher!
Bring the key higher up or we'll be fucked over by the...
the thing.
The key won't move.
Oh, you can pass it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm passing it.
Okay, I'll pass it to you.
Okay, I guess not.
We gotta be patient.
Please, we have the key.
The person ahead has to have the key!
No, I don't want it to be me!
I don't have the key.
Alright, go.
You have the key.
Alright, you go.
I don't want the key.
Whose phone?
Okay.
I'm gonna wait for the thing.
I'm scared.
Go!
Okay.
Three, two, one, go!
How do I?
Okay, that's okay.
Now!
Yay!
Now you guys can do it.
Careful.
Don't panic.
Nice.
Be patient.
Careful, SpongeBob.
I'm scared.
Please, we don't wanna do this again.
You don't have a choice.
I wanna master this level.
Let's do it one more time.
Let's get a speedrun, guys.
Let's run faster for sure.
Yeah, we could really honestly be faster.
We could actually be on speedrun.com, guys.
If we, like, perfect the time.
Oh my god.
I'm back!
My own wish came true, it seems.
You got your wish, Randy.
There's actually no way.
We were basically done.
Why did you run back?
I will jump over your head.
This is insane.
Run for your life.
I can't get over there.
Oh no.
Let's go!
Oh god.
I think we've learned from this that we would all be the first to die in a horror movie.
Hey, hey, hey.
What do you mean?
I don't know what you're talking about.
Oh man.
Oh god.
It's okay.
Everything is fine.
We'll just leave Rin down there.
Woah, woah, woah.
It's all up to you.
Try again.
I don't want to try again.
Wait, so who's white?
Oh my god, it was all Malik.
Alright.
We got this.
It's okay.
We'll get the world record now.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's a funny one.
You guys can actually go up more than one by one.
Yeah.
Okay.
Alright.
We shimmy until we head...
Okay, there we go.
Let's go.
Single file line.
Remember guys.
Sorry.
Why are you saying sorry?
I'm sorry little one.
Go, go, go.
I can't wait.
I have to wait to see.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Okay, can't.
I didn't have to wait for a guy.
I could just move.
I'm
fast.
Alright.
Nice.
I'm ahead.
Oh my god.
I think you're like wall hacking.
Hey guys.
Hi.
You're doing so bad.
It doesn't matter.
I'm done already.
I'm stuck.
I'm not letting you jump past me.
We gotta work together.
We're so bad.
This is the run.
That was good.
This is the run guys.
This is it.
I'll walk over so you guys can...
Okay.
That's a good plan.
You just gotta get there.
Just get up here guys.
Can't be that bad.
Guys it's right here.
You know what you're saying.
We can do this.
Alright.
I don't want to be in front anymore.
Stop pushing me.
Okay guys.
We can't be on top of each other.
I'm not touching you.
You're touching my aura.
Be ready.
Uh oh.
Go go go.
Two can be at the same time.
Guys.
It's on fire.
Okay.
I think you just don't understand the mechanics.
It's on fire.
What happened?
You have to jump.
If it starts moving up you jump.
And it'll go back down even faster.
You're trying to leave.
I am but there are people all the way to me.
How do you do that?
Oh then you have to stop dying.
We die!
No that's not true.
That's not true.
How?
Stop slapping the...
Oh sorry.
The on your peak game for Pico Park.
It starts so...
Ever since the grey incident It's never been the same.
Our motivation is gone.
Like my will to live.
Okay, here we go.
The jumping will not work if there's tons of you on the platform.
Because you would all have to jump at exactly the same time.
So try not to stack.
Yeah, we got it right the first time.
What happened to us?
It happened.
Which last time?
And then greed happened.
We're becoming masters of this level.
It's fine.
That's not something to be proud of.
We're going to be so good for the next one.
Yeah, we're going to be so good at chapter 2.
If we beat chapter 15 with like zero knowledge, we got this.
Okay.
Someone do an example just to make sure we know what to do at this point.
Alright guys, let's practice.
Alright, here we go.
We're practicing.
Your turn.
One at a time.
Okay.
Guys.
Lime would have been dead already, guys.
Lime would have been dead.
I feel like we have to have a drill sergeant.
Okay, alright, alright.
This is a fire drill.
Yeah, children, this is a fire drill.
Okay?
Imagine if there's a fire, alright?
Now what do we do?
We practice again?
Okay, this is the run.
This is the run.
There's a fire.
It's life or death.
Guys.
Okay.
Alright, get the key closed.
The first person has to unlock the door.
I don't want to be up here.
Okay.
Guys.
Guys, please.
There's a green goblin on my head.
Okay.
You're unlocking.
Alright.
Oh no.
Go to the fire.
Okay.
Alright, Min.
It's up to you.
I'm waiting for it.
Okay.
Don't answer the call of the void.
Alright.
Nice.
Okay.
We can do it now.
Alright.
Let's go back.
Okay.
I don't think we should...
I don't think we should risk that.
Wait.
Wait till it goes back.
Oh, nice.
Nice.
Okay.
I'll go first.
Slow and steady.
Amelie, you go next.
Okay.
Now we should be good.
Let's have that thing.
Go back up and down.
No!
Okay.
Nice.
Nice!
Yeah!
We are finally on schedule.
Oh my god.
We did it.
I held my breath.
I feel like that is...
How do I get out of...
How do I get out of 15?
Don't you go back there.
Okay.
Now...
Let's learn the game.
Let's learn the game, guys.
Now why were we on level 15?
Oh no.
What is this?
Oh, it hurts.
It can kill us.
Guys, guys, please!
Oh, I see.
Please.
Just don't die.
Okay, you guys.
Guys, we jump over it.
We can jump over it.
Just don't let it hit you.
Guys, Bailey.
It's like those kindergarten leashes, guys.
You can stand on it.
Yes, you can stand on it.
Look at me stand.
I see.
It's the velocity that got you.
I was doing my bad part.
Alright.
Apologies.
Okay, the order changes every time.
Oh, it's pushing me.
I wasn't even pressing my key.
The order changes every time, guys.
Okay.
Alright.
I can't jump if you're on my head.
Now who could that be?
Something about a chunky butt.
Okay.
Okay, dice.
Alright, let's go.
Oh, no.
We're tangled.
We are tangled.
Okay, so.
We have to stack.
Doki, doki, swap with me.
Oh, I see.
Okay.
Okay, stacking time.
Will you drag us all with us?
Yes, I have no idea.
I think so.
I mean like...
Like, okay, we need you to get up.
I can't move!
I actually can't stop letting you!
Oh, there we go.
There we go.
Don't push me off the edge!
Okay, okay.
Mr. Purple, can you...
I don't feel so good about this.
I can't move now either.
Okay.
And then...
Oh, okay!
Okay!
And then...
Pink just needs to jump over.
Okay, okay.
And then you drag the purple...
Yes!
We did it!
Oh, we have to do that again.
Where am I supposed to be?
Okay, we must lower you off the side.
Alright, it's a tug of war.
Nobody dies!
Okay, let's all just jump off.
Let's all just jump off.
And then we'll just lower you down.
And what order are we in?
Okay.
We should untangle real quick.
I am here.
I can't tell at all.
Okay, there we go.
How do we do this?
Oh, we have to stack maybe again?
I think that's just a jump.
I think you jump.
Why would they do that if it weren't for the level design?
Maybe.
Okay.
Oh, we lost the key.
Oh, I got it!
Okay.
Let's try again.
Oh no, we have to be untangled.
Okay, what is...
This is so romantic.
What if like...
What if like two or three of us jump at the same time?
Oh, true, true.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Two of you guys jump.
We should untangle before we do that.
Okay.
I am here.
Purple is next to me.
Red is next to me.
Oh my god.
How did you guys get tangled like that?
You guys are not even...
I'm so stressed.
I don't know actually.
We're doing a star.
I'm supposed to be over here.
What's she wearing?
Okay.
You are still tangled.
There's some double looping going on on that rope.
I'm pretty sure.
No, I think it's fine.
I think it's just graphic.
Okay.
I think you guys have to jump off of my head for this.
Eight, four, and six have to jump together.
Yeah.
We should get closer so that they don't get pulled back.
Yeah, right here.
Okay.
Alright.
We did it.
We need to pull these cats up.
Help.
Here we go.
Okay.
Now what?
Untangle.
Alright.
How come it's always the tail end that's tangled up like that?
How come?
What are you guys doing?
We're fine over here.
We don't have problems.
Yeah, we're here.
It's not me, man.
Why are you guys tangling up even more?
Guys, why are you guys tangling up even more?
You guys untangled and then tangled yourself again.
Okay, fine.
If you're so perfect over here, then why don't you be a little bit more tangled, okay?
Yeah, yeah.
You saw them.
Yeah.
This wasn't for you.
Yeah, yeah.
Alright, fine.
Let's swap.
Let's swap places.
We'll swap places.
The back will be in the front.
Let's go.
The back will be in front.
Go back.
Go.
We can do this.
This is just like the rubber bands.
Guys, where are you guys?
Guys, guys.
No, no, no.
Trust.
Okay.
We should just jump so we can be untangled.
If we jump, we lose our key.
Okay, alright.
Okay, let's just get these guys out here first.
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, we're just gonna jump.
Alright, let's just do a jump.
Let's just jump.
It's fine.
It's not gonna work.
Holy shit.
What is this?
If we make a staircase and then we have someone fall into the gap.
Yes, I have a suggestion.
Without tangling, we do need to make a staircase and have someone on the end then jump off.
Okay.
Not like that.
Guys, I got pushed.
I got pushed, guys.
Somebody pushed me.
Okay, so this way we need to have in reverse order, so someone needs to be on doki that is between...
Someone needs to be under doki.
Yeah, purple under doki.
Okay, like that.
There you go.
So if you get to the edge, and then I jump, that will hopefully be enough.
Maybe.
Alright, nice.
Oh, Steve, look at that!
The backend figured it out!
Look at that!
The backend figured it out, guys.
Big brain.
Okay, we have to...
At least we can't die here.
Okay, guys, guys.
We need at least a couple of us to pull the others off.
The people on the bottom of the stack need to walk off at the same time.
Alright.
So we need to all stack into a big group.
Like a huge group.
Alright, guys.
And then we need to walk off at the same time.
So true.
Um...
Okay, blue and red, you walk off and I can jump.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Alright.
I believe!
Push!
I shouldn't have had those toddlers.
Okay, okay, okay.
Guys, guys.
We don't have to move, guys.
Just stay still.
Everybody stay still.
I need...
I need you to touch the wall.
Okay.
Alright.
And then...
Okay, okay.
No, no, no, no.
Rin, stay on top.
Okay.
And then Snuffy... Oh, no.
I don't think I can.
No, Snuffy has to move.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then I can jump.
And then we all move.
There we go!
Oh my gosh, I literally got carried away.
This whole time.
Yay!
Our one brain cell, Lime, is working overtime right now.
Okay, don't...
Don't touch me!
Oh my gosh, we have a health bar.
Okay.
We were basically dead.
We have one HP!
Guys, let's do it.
I'm okay.
We have so much HP.
Someone get on here, but don't touch me.
Guys, six feet, guys.
Six feet.
Guys, guys, guys.
Guys, I don't want it.
Guys, please.
This is slippery.
Slippery.
There's ice up there.
It's ice.
Oh, it's ice.
Doki, don't touch me.
Don't touch me, Doki!
I'm not even moving!
Yes, you are!
You're moving towards me!
I just break -checked you, Doki!
I just break-checked you!
No, no, don't touch me, though.
Whoa, whoa, whoa!
Stop!
It's hot enough!
Go!
Alright, go!
Sorry, it's ice.
Be careful.
Sorry!
Okay.
Oh, wait.
Oh, shit.
I was trying to go back for you.
Okay, you first.
You first.
What does this do?
Why are you sliding it into each other?
Scoot along a bit further.
Well, I need you to scoot so I can go... No, I need you to... Okay, well, I guess that worked out.
Nobody touch me!
Don't touch!
Well...
Oh, sorry!
Oh, hey, we didn't touch, though.
I think you did, because...
Oh, oh!
That was our fault.
There we go.
I'm not afraid to use it.
Try not to jump off early if you're on the right, because you leave your friend behind.
There we go.
Oh, whoa!
Slip and slide there.
Uh, uh, uh.
Guys, just...
Yeah, yeah, just do a little jump.
Just do a little jump.
Okay.
There we go, there we go.
Okay, and then we jump at the same time.
Okay, oh, that's...
Oh, sorry.
Um, I know what those words mean.
Okay, three, two, one...
Jump!
Oh, no, no, we're fine.
Everything's fine.
Okay, we each get a button, I guess?
Yeah, I think so.
Why are you always looking back at me?
Gentle, gentle.
Stop.
I'm looking at you.
Stop looking at me.
Okay, okay, nice.
We just won.
Okay, I just got a...
Oh, my gosh, you look so crazy.
All right.
I'm doing my part.
Don't touch me!
I'm not even pressing anything.
Yeah, me too.
I'm just lying.
Oh, okay, never mind.
Oh, it doesn't kill you.
That's so good.
Oh, that's so good.
My apologies.
It doesn't kill you.
That's just the way.
Wait, I twirl.
Oh, my gosh.
That's just the way.
Yippee!
Yay!
Ah, yes.
I'm sweating.
I'm almost done with the game.
My palms are moist.
Oh, it's the...
You know what I want to hear in this game?
Oh, it's this again.
Look, there's fireworks.
Oh, we can touch again.
Yeah.
I'mma go back.
I can't.
That's exactly where I was.
There we go.
Easy peasy.
Are we doing the same thing?
Oh, I think we're in the sack.
Snuffy, is this you?
Snuffy, am I touching you right now?
I'm the pink one.
Oh, you're even more pink.
Wait, who am I touching?
That's Rin.
Oh, hi, Rin.
Hi, Rin.
Okay, and then I'm up here.
Good.
You gotta jump with us.
Yeah, jump.
Okay, and then...
Just don't kick us down.
Okay.
All right.
Let's reverse it.
Back of the line, everybody.
Back.
Okay.
All right.
Okay, okay.
I was a little too eager.
I'm sorry.
All right.
Here we go again.
We've all been there.
Okay.
Ready for the release.
I'm sorry.
Don't fall down the hall.
Don't fall down.
I'm giving us more room.
If you don't make it, we all die.
Do a play.
Oh, what?
What?
It punched me backwards.
I don't know what to do.
Three of us have to jump over.
I think a few of us have to jump at the same time.
All right.
Here we go.
Guys.
What the fuck am I looking at here?
All right.
I think we gotta untangle first.
I am supposed to be not here.
Red.
Green.
Oh my god, please.
We were almost.
Okay.
There we go.
We did it.
Okay.
No, no, no.
All right.
Here we go.
This is it.
One more time.
Surely this time.
This is it.
Gray, orange, and green should all go?
No, I think gray goes first.
Gray walks off, maybe.
Three, two, one.
Who's going?
Go.
Why did we all go?
Why did we all walk?
That was so close.
Why did we all walk forward?
I think everyone does need to be going.
Yeah.
Okay.
No, no.
I don't think everybody.
I think it has to be like the top four walk off and then...
There's enough weight on the other side.
It's definitely one on one person.
I think we need three people to pull the rest of us across.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
All right.
I believe.
I'm losing my fucking mind at this music right now.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Just remember Pico Park was worse.
I'm sorry.
Normally, so I kind of like it.
I'm at peace.
Okay.
Somebody is not where they're supposed to be.
I should be in the back or the front, I guess.
The two ends are at the same end.
Yeah.
All right.
Okay.
Now this is a lot more tangled.
Here we go.
Okay.
This is it.
There we go.
Okay.
Purple, then red, then yellow.
Yeah.
All right.
Now we climb.
I cannot move.
I cannot allow you in.
Now we climb.
There we go.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Climb the mountain.
Climb up.
Your friends more.
All right.
There you go.
Okay.
Look at how much room you have.
You can't miss.
You literally can't miss.
It's right there.
Just walk.
Okay.
Right.
There you go.
No, no, no.
We're done.
Why did that happen?
I'm happy.
You don't know how to keep walking forward.
I'm going to be sick.
Who stopped walking?
What?
You stopped.
Oh, Christ.
Somebody's hand was off the keyboard.
Oh, dear.
We all got to pull our parts.
Okay.
Stack, stack, stack.
Stack time.
Who do we stack on?
Stack, stack, stack.
Okay.
Stack time.
Stack, stack.
Holy shit.
Okay.
All right.
Boo, you can't.
Oh, okay.
Oh, there we go.
There we go.
Okay.
Right.
A little bit more, too.
Okay.
There's no way we can't.
One.
Go, go, go.
Just one.
Go back.
No.
That's been a miscommunication.
Okay.
Two to three.
That's there.
In order, I guess.
In order.
Okay.
We figured it out.
Wait.
I'm behind you.
Three.
All right.
Here we go.
Four.
We need this.
It has to be like this.
You don't jump.
I can't jump.
Pull her back.
Okay.
Only one person needs to...
That's too far.
Okay.
Now we bring...
Now...
You just jump.
You just gotta jump.
I am trying to jump, but the weight is fucking me up.
Are you sure it shouldn't be the person on the end?
Oh, Rin.
You might be a little bit too heavy, Rin.
Help me.
Oh, I know.
I know.
We have to...
One has to be tangled.
Maybe.
Oh, Deska.
I think it's just the dangle, right?
And then the next person goes.
Yeah, I think just someone at the end, maybe.
Because then we can easily pull them up.
Probably.
I feel like there should be someone in the middle, no?
Because I cannot see... What's the puzzle?
I didn't see it.
It's a button that they have to dangle down.
No, there's the key in the middle.
I don't know if you have to hit the buttons or what.
Or avoid them.
Oh, that's close.
I kind of need that.
I feel like...
We probably have to be careful on that for a reason.
We can just like play with it, you know?
I think the buttons are bad news.
No, we can jump.
Maybe it's like as many people as possible jump across and then one goes down and you have to counterbalance it between the three.
Let's try.
Okay, pull me up.
Thank you, man.
Don't go too far.
We're tangled up, but we did it.
Alright, now we jump across.
Let's just get maybe four of us.
Guys, please.
I'm in between you two.
Hold on, guys.
Don't go too far.
Keep jumping.
Who is that over there?
We need to go left.
Now we walk across.
And then we jump.
Okay.
If we...
Oh, and then we can drag.
Yeah, let's drag.
You fall between the cracks.
Juniper, don't jump.
You just fall.
Can I dangle?
No, no, no.
I'm going down.
My life is in your hands.
Yeah.
Oh, okay.
I said the button.
Guys.
Yes.
I'm talking.
I think we're right.
We do need to be super tangled.
So that the line is shorter.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Dangle her.
Emily, you go down.
Okay, okay.
And then we pull up.
We gotta pull up.
Three more apart.
Wait, wait.
Jump on top of someone, right?
Yeah, yeah.
So I'm connected to one and two.
One and two just need to be farther apart.
The farther apart you are, the shorter the line.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I can't jump.
We need you guys to untangle.
One and two.
Okay.
There we go.
Nice, guys.
And then...
Farther apart.
Okay.
Nice.
And then...
We're so bad.
All right.
Nice.
Oh, my goodness.
We're so smart.
We've done the impossible.
We did it.
We actually did it.
Oh, my God.
We're so smart.
Am I the only one tall enough to ride the ride?
Yeah.
We're too straight.
You just got carried the whole time.
Get in the backpack.
Amelie, can you talk for me?
I need to adjust your volume.
I couldn't even register what was happening.
Pass me one, two, three.
That's better.
Thank you.
I think I need to change Juniper, too.
What's that?
Oh, yeah.
Push the box.
Oh, I have to push the box?
Yeah.
Because you're orange.
Okay, guys.
I can't move.
Sorry.
I was looking back after adjusting Discord.
I think we start over.
We start over.
No.
We don't... Okay.
Okay.
Yeah.
We need the full help.
I know us.
That's the box.
All right.
This time, it's Amelie.
That's the box.
Okay.
I'm not even moving.
Like, how are you guys hitting me?
Jump over you.
Amelie, it's your box.
It's your box.
It's the Amelie box.
We have to jump over her.
Okay.
Jump over.
Trash can.
She's collecting the trash.
I'm sorry.
I shocked you.
Don't beat the trash man.
All right.
I'm not moving and you touched me.
It's your fault.
I'm not moving.
I know.
Oh, no.
Whacked me on life.
I only have a few brain cells.
Oh.
Oh, it pushes you back.
It pushes you back.
Oh, no.
There's a hole.
Okay.
Oh, it's timed.
Timed.
I see.
Okay.
Yeah.
So we wait.
Go.
Okay.
Why didn't you jump across?
Guys, we have one HP left.
Guys.
Jump up if you can.
One health is all we need.
Keep moving.
We would have died anyway.
Okay.
My turn.
Guys.
Okay.
It's your box now.
Jump over my head.
Oh.
Okay.
Alright.
Get over here.
You guys gotta jump over me, guys.
I really gotta jump over me.
My bad.
I forgot how this works.
It's my box.
Okay.
Alright.
I am not moving, so you touch me.
It's your fault.
I'm not moving.
There's plenty of space.
Okay.
No, there's not.
There's plenty of space.
Oh, no.
Hey, guys.
It's gonna touch me.
Guys, I need you guys.
Okay.
Here you go.
Alright.
Just run forward.
Just go.
There's nothing down there.
What do you mean there's nothing down there?
Just go.
Donkey, go.
Look at me.
I'm literally kissing the wall right now.
I'm literally kissing the wall.
We're gonna be okay.
Eventually.
Bye-bye.
There's plenty of room.
Donkey, just go for it.
I'm kissing the wall.
Oh, my God.
We only have three hands left.
That's so gross.
Jesus.
Wait.
How do we get the key?
How do we...
You gotta make a jump, I think.
Okay.
Not like that.
We have to be careful.
I didn't realize it was me at the end.
I didn't realize each other.
I think one of us...
We need to save one HP.
So we can stack and get the key.
Yeah.
I agree.
Brilliant.
Okay.
In the ideal scenario, we save all of the HP.
No.
That's...
I think you're asking too much from us.
That's too much.
Alright.
Amelie, your turn.
Amelie.
Alright.
I didn't move!
Yay.
Oh.
Don't worry.
You have another try.
Alright.
Go, go, go.
Nice.
My turn.
See, I made it.
I'm waiting for it.
I got nervous.
It's okay.
You push up.
You got to kiss the wall.
We're getting performance anxiety in Pico Park.
Okay.
There's plenty of space, guys.
You can make the jump.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh.
She's gaming.
Okay.
Relax.
Yeah.
There you go.
Guys, don't touch.
There's a lot of room, guys.
There's a lot of...
I didn't move.
I didn't even...
It's okay.
The wall won't hurt you.
Yeah.
You just can't touch each other.
Logically, maybe.
It's hurting me.
It's hurting my mind.
Oh, there's a van.
We got a key.
Nice.
Go.
What's going to happen to that?
Oh, it's just going to push us up.
It's just going to...
Only six.
Come on.
Okay.
Don't...
We all know how to count, right, guys?
We all know how to count.
Yeah.
Wait.
It's going to go down into the water, right?
Okay.
Guys, shimmy.
We're fine.
We can do this.
Who said we can do this?
Yeah.
Guys, we beat level 15.
We can beat level 2.
We got this.
There's the needle.
There we go.
Make way.
Nice.
All right.
Make way.
Beep.
Okay.
All right.
You're welcome.
I don't think she trusts us on making the jump.
I don't think...
I don't think life trusts us in parkour.
Is the thing going to...
Is the thing going?
It's just kind of like...
Okay.
No, we're good.
I'll grab the key so don't come through.
I'm staying completely still.
I believe.
Wait.
Yeah.
Do not continue, friends.
Do not continue.
Okay.
Oh.
No.
Someone else is pushing.
Someone else has got to get the key.
Good luck.
Okay, Mint.
I believe in you.
I can't do this.
You guys have to go forward.
You don't get it either.
It's got to be the next person.
Guys.
I don't know.
Three people at once is a good idea.
I don't...
Why are you coming back off?
I didn't think that was a good idea.
Yes.
Remember.
What is happening over there?
Yes.
Remember.
Figure it out.
Alright.
I'm going to get smushed.
I need you guys to move forward.
Purple needs to move forward.
Red.
Move forward.
Okay.
Don't worry.
I learned how to park before.
Okay.
We're fine.
One at a time.
Guys.
I'm not trying to make you nervous.
I'm just scooting.
What was that?
One last life, guys.
It's okay.
One last life.
Red.
We need to scoot over a little bit.
Who touched me?
Who is freaking moving?
Why can we not respect?
Personal space.
Nobody moved.
Why can't we respect personal space?
Please.
We had two years to practice six feet.
We had two years of isolation.
And you still don't know personal space.
Sorry.
That's a mess.
My broken bones.
This is not the run, bros.
Okay.
Let's just die.
We're close.
Nobody moved at the beginning.
I'm dead.
It was like five people in a row.
Okay.
This is it.
Chungus.
The Chungus head.
I'm moving.
Chungus head.
Okay.
Keep moving a little bit.
Okay, daughter.
Okay.
That was personal, I think.
Alright.
This is fine.
That's for dying on level 15.
Never forget.
Never forgive.
We know what you did.
You made us do the run five more times.
Okay.
I'm going.
One together.
Okay.
One of you guys has to do the jump.
Bao, I believe in you.
Okay.
Don't go.
Big.
Can you guys move forward?
Yeah.
Alright.
Okay.
We have enough room for all three of you guys technically.
Technically?
Yeah.
I mean, see?
I told you.
Alright.
Are we all ready?
Yes.
Oh yeah.
Get ready.
Do the jump.
Okay.
Go.
Go to the end and scoot left.
Okay.
Keep scooting.
Scooting.
Who's not scooting?
Who's not scooting back there?
Okay.
Please.
We're good.
Now we get off.
Get off.
Open the door.
Okay.
Just go.
Go.
Okay.
Let's go.
Oh lord.
Distance is complete.
I can feel the tension in my brain.
We can go.
We're so good at video games.
We're gonna be such great friends after this game.
Formation.
We're still gonna be friends you think?
Formation guys.
What is this?
It's a pee break.
No one's gonna piss.
This isn't the epilepsy level is it?
Someone has to piss.
Okay.
Go use the bathroom.
We'll figure this out while you're gone.
It's just red light green light.
Oh okay.
Guys the light hurts.
I think it was Juniper.
It was not me.
I am quiet.
I think it was Amelie then.
Okay.
So light hurts.
Yeah.
That's just how it is.
As a gamer.
Okay so it's...
There's only enough space.
I think there's only enough space for a stack.
We could stack.
Go here.
We can't stack too high because there's so little light.
Stack it.
Oh my goodness.
Wait what if we all just stack?
Oh that's true.
No no no.
I think we'll get the light.
We can do three.
So we could do groups of three.
Or four.
Get behind me.
Wait.
Oh.
I have four gore.
Four gore?
Can we do four?
I think we can do four.
We definitely can.
We have space for four.
Four gore.
So.
Emily can just be a solo.
Oh okay.
Brain damage.
I mean after that last level.
Everyone on top of your head.
Yeah.
Wait no we can stack like this.
Wow.
This is so funny.
Okay nice.
It's fine.
She can solo this.
I believe.
She is.
Guys I don't think.
Guys I told you.
I told you.
Hey welcome back.
She can't solo this.
Wait no.
We shouldn't let her solo this.
We can get five.
Okay.
Oh sorry.
I bet we could make a perfect diamond pyramid.
Oh that's true.
Let's do it.
Let's show our beautiful skills.
Yeah yeah.
I need you to move to the right a little bit.
Exactly.
Do we have enough room to make a perfect diamond?
Yeah we can.
There we go.
It's beautiful.
This is not a diamond.
We can stack two people on top of us too.
Maybe purple jump on top too.
Yeah.
Purple.
How does pink get up?
Rin.
Rin jump.
And then.
We must realign.
How does snuffy get up?
Maybe green make a little room.
I can move a little bit.
Let's see if red can get on top of Baal.
I am on top of Baal.
Oh guys we are getting closer to the left.
Okay.
Don't do it too close up.
Let's not assemble that.
Okay.
Let's just do five.
We are making it too fancy.
Okay.
I can have another person on Baal.
I want snuffy's pyramid to happen though.
Okay.
Wait.
Who is going to be at the bottom?
No.
Baal is going to be at the bottom here.
I can choose one person to be at the bottom.
Yes.
It can be this tall.
This is as tall as it can be.
Okay.
It can't be any bigger than two at the bottom.
I am pretty sure.
We did it.
Okay.
Now you can stack up.
Why did you walk right?
Why did you?
Why?
We just need two different stacks.
That's no need to over complicate this.
It's fancy.
We wanted to be a beautiful pyramid.
You pyramid haters.
We are already beautiful.
My bad.
Pyramid Johns always wants it.
That's the reason it's called a pyramid scheme.
I hear you.
I get it.
Okay.
Look at that.
Now we are a boring line.
We can't have nice things guys.
I love boring lines.
That was just a lie.
Oh my god.
Okay.
This is fine.
I still trust Bao despite her failure.
Failure?
Okay.
So what happened was...
I don't think I trust Bao at the bottom anymore.
I still trust Bao.
I am a professional.
Last chance Bao.
You die.
We are swapping bottoms.
Goodbye.
It's okay.
I will catch up.
Don't worry.
Um...
Don't catch up.
But what about me?
Now I can catch up.
I trust Bao.
I can't go anywhere.
I would give Bao a gun.
Give Bao a gun.
Okay.
There you go.
Alright.
I would not give Bao a gun.
Alright, Bao.
You've lost your bottom privileges.
You've lost it.
Maybe I trust Rin more.
That's a dangerous statement.
And that's what happens when you don't fully trust the one at the bottom.
when you don't fully trust the one at the bottom.
Maybe we should swap the bottom.
Someone giving you my face.
Stop fighting.
Alright.
Here we go.
Okay, alright.
I think it has to be a line.
No, it doesn't have to be.
It's too dangerous.
I was throwing, but now I'm gonna lock in for real.
Okay, let's realign us to be a perfect line.
There we go.
There we go, so...
Alright, here we go.
You're getting awfully close there, Bao!
You're getting awfully close there!
Get up!
Okay.
Oh, there's light on there.
Guys, this is just the first obstacle.
I don't like it.
I feel like it has to be a key there.
How the fuck does this work?
Oh my god.
Checkpoint!
They knew.
They knew deep down that this level was gonna be nice.
Oh, there's a key!
There's a key!
Go back!
We have to do the trust run.
Oh, more people have gotta get people over there.
Okay, it's fine.
Okay.
Okay, so wait.
Hold on.
We gotta run.
Y'all just gotta run.
I'm sprinting!
You have trapped me on the platform!
Okay, I'm good.
Okay, wait.
We can stack this up!
We can stack this up technically.
I don't trust you, Dolly!
Okay.
There you go.
See, I told you.
I told you we could stack this up.
But like, I can't go downstairs.
I can't...
Why are you... Why are you...
Thank God almighty for the checkpoint.
More than we needed it.
Yay!
We're going in.
That was so funny.
Can we move the camera over, I think?
Yeah, someone has to move the camera over.
I'll move the camera.
Okay.
Bum-bum-bum.
Not being moved.
No!
I need more people to come at the same time.
Okay, everyone get on top of me!
Stack!
We just gotta stack all the way up.
There's no light that's gonna hurt us.
Trust me.
All you have to do is get on top of me.
Yeah, yeah.
She's done this like three times now.
There's no way she can fuck it up.
No way we lose these.
He's stacking!
I have a little... Okay.
Green, move a little bit forward.
Yup.
There we go.
Purple, move forward.
Wait, why?
We're ready.
Alright.
Okay.
Are you ready?
Trust the process.
Go!
Okay!
Back up!
As soon as it disappears!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Go!
Oh, we did it!
We did it!
Yay!
What?!
I hate this!
No way!
That's fucking way!
Trust me.
Hand me the gun.
Okay.
Put it in my hands.
Just jury and execution.
Alright, here we go.
Alright.
We just hug the left wall after we get over.
Yeah, we're gonna fall and then not move.
Okay.
After this one.
Yeah.
Okay.
Go!
Alright, we're just gonna fall and not move.
Just fall!
Fall!
Okay, okay!
Okay!
Go!
Oh, I don't think guys got the thing!
We have too much time!
Easy game.
We all just ran.
Like, what the fuck?
Every man for themselves.
Not if you can't.
You guys all just ran.
I know, right?
We have to all be on it.
This is gonna be great, I think.
Yeah, I think there's gonna go be an obstacle down the front.
Oh, oh!
Line!
Okay!
Oh!
Okay, okay!
We got the little hole.
We got...
Next try baby!
We're in the game!
Okay...
To the right.
I think, I think..
Wait, this has to be...
Okay, but we're getting there.
Okay, we're figuring it out.
Okay, line, line.
No stacks, line, line.
Is anyone else?
Okay.
Part the middle, part the middle.
Part the C!
Okay, there we go.
It's like Noah.
Left, left.
We have to stack, we have to stack.
We have to stay in the middle.
When it starts going down.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Stack in the middle.
Line, line, line.
Okay.
I keep thinking you guys are specifically yelling at me.
Part the C.
We're yelling at everybody.
Now we have to stack in the middle.
Stack in the middle.
I'm trusting you guys, please.
Stack in the middle, there we go.
Oh, look at us go.
Okay, we did it.
Okay, what horrible tribulation will come next?
That's it?
Okay, the key.
That was pretty easy.
Okay, keys, key, key.
When you get the key and you put it...
Yeah, and then you get the key and then you put in the hole and then I got the key and then we're here.
Okay.
That's how you put the key in the hole.
Playing hot potato with the key.
Actually, the hardest part was getting that key in the hole.
Wait, was that really time shot?
No, no, they were fucking over.
Oh, no.
No, not the suck.
I've got utility.
What's the skill?
Okay.
Bow, you don't suck.
You let get sucked.
Okay.
Just jump.
There we go.
This is so cool.
Okay, alright.
What's happening here?
Wait, how does this...
We have to be aligned.
So, like...
So, everybody's a suck in the line.
Suck free.
Jump.
Just jump.
Trust fall.
Jump.
No, you suck.
I suck you.
Alright.
Each of us holds square, guys.
Not square.
Each of us holds space bar.
You're supposed to wait for us.
We have to be all sucked up.
Okay.
You suck me.
This one, it blows my mind.
I don't even know what this is.
Okay.
So, Bow gonna suck.
I suck.
We all suck together.
And then Bow pushes us forward.
Huh?
So, we're all gripped up.
And then she pushes...
So, you see... Yeah, we're all gripped up.
And then Bow, you... Okay, we lost our platform.
So, okay.
Thank god.
Okay.
Alright.
Now...
Do I have to be on the end?
Because I don't know how to join the suck.
We all suck.
We all...
No, no, no.
You all go face right side.
You all face right and then Bow pushes us.
And then I hold you guys.
Yeah, yeah.
We all hold each other like groups of friends.
Okay.
What?
And then there you go as the... Okay.
Somebody let go.
Wait, how is that gonna help?
Oh my god.
We are creating a perpetual motion machine.
It's artificial gravity.
Okay.
We're creating a perpetual motion machine.
I don't understand.
Physics kneels before Pico Pops.
Okay.
Is there like a zig-zag pattern?
No, no, no.
When you put the magnet in front of the car.
We do need to be in a line.
Why wouldn't it work?
The person on the end of the line needs to be on the far right hand side of the platform.
So, when the platform goes up, they don't collide with the platform.
So, they have to hold everybody else off the platform while standing on the very end of the platform by themselves.
I'm pretty sure.
And that's how you suck.
Yeah, we all need to suck real hard.
We all face the same direction guys while you're sucking.
Face the same direction everybody.
And we're... The end as well?
Yeah, yeah.
Yes, you all face and then you push us out.
You push us up.
The rest of us do not move.
Do not move.
You do not move.
And then you grab the key and then we still do not move.
Okay, we have to swap directions.
I see it now.
We have to reverse the suck now.
Okay, we have to reverse that.
Alright.
Okay.
The rest of...
I'll be at the end.
Stop.
Okay, here we go.
You guys ready?
Do not move guys.
Do not move everybody.
Alright, and then we turn around.
You guys all turn around and then bounce.
You go right and you go...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
None of us move.
Trust.
There we go.
Big.
Slow.
Come on.
We're getting better.
Trust.
Okay, guys.
Okay, I got you guys.
Emily, face the right side.
Oh, wait.
I'll be at this side.
Okay, here we go.
Alright.
Push, push, push up so we can connect.
Here we go.
No one let go.
No one move.
Except for...
Somebody trying to let go.
You're trolling.
Okay.
Alright.
Somebody is knocking.
Okay.
All the way back.
You're okay.
Here we go.
We're fine.
Alright.
Here we go.
We made it.
Oh my god.
Yay.
I saw what you guys...
Okay, guys.
One at a time.
Yay.
We sucked the victory.
Oh.
My brain.
We sucked so hard.
I feel like... I can feel the pressure on my brain.
I feel like my brain just got sucked.
Wait, remember what?
What's happening?
It's sucking again.
Just remember your own spot.
Where's my color?
Which one is me?
I remember a goddamn thing.
I remember.
I was here.
I'm here.
I don't know where I'm supposed to be.
I was down here.
I was here.
I was literally just doing this.
Now we're kissing.
Guys, you guys remember?
Oh my god.
Oh, you guys have to push those squares too.
Am I here?
I think I'm here.
Guys, you have to remember where your squares are too.
You have to remember.
You have to move the blocks.
Oh, we have to move the blocks.
Let's see if you guys remember.
Where are we?
Guys, I don't think...
Okay, I got it.
We have the blocks.
Why didn't you read it?
We fucked up.
That's wrong.
Wow.
You were so fucking wrong.
Okay.
I was right.
Remember your squares.
And I gotta be on the ledge.
Okay, I know what I'm doing.
It's gonna be great.
Okay.
Purple's gotta push their square all the way downstairs.
I have a box.
I got this.
I'm pretty sure I do nothing.
I don't do anything either.
Oh, wait.
No, no.
Wait, box, come back.
Don't drop my box.
Oh my god.
You guys are here.
I don't know.
I don't know why I did it.
Can we redo?
Huge.
Oh, my beautiful box.
Hi.
She was begging you and you still didn't.
Oh, I was right.
Oh, I was facing the wrong way.
Are they gonna get mad at me?
I remember the game was like, well, Rin did it right.
I didn't face the right direction, so it's right.
What is it that you want?
I want a box.
We're so good.
Test your memory.
No, I have to do the box now.
I'm looking at my stream preview.
Okay, I'm here.
I'm here.
The box is here.
Okay, I just need to be next to Rin.
I need to chill out with Doki.
Wait, I thought I was blue for some reason.
I've already messed up.
I'm set.
I'm chilling.
I messed it all up, bro.
I don't know what to do.
I am successful.
I'm flirting.
Maybe you don't know what to do.
I thought I was blue for some reason.
I was looking at Bao's voice on the map for no reason.
You fool.
Push the box a little bit to the right.
To the right, Bao, please.
She can't.
She's blue.
Oh my gosh.
Where's Juniper?
I was just guessing.
I was looking at the wrong person.
Juniper.
I thought you threw.
I threw, bros.
I threw.
We were so close.
That's all me, baby.
Okay, no more box.
Over your box.
Two pieces to the left.
My box is slightly here.
I love this for me.
Okay, I'm here.
I'm here.
I'm done.
Guys, please.
Easiest assignment ever.
Okay, there you go.
Good luck, everybody else.
Yeah, I get to stay here.
Get your box, please.
What the fuck is this box doing over here?
Get this box out of my face.
Do you remember where your box was?
Okay, I'm done.
I don't remember where it was.
Wait, please.
No.
Wait, that might be good.
No, no, no.
We were so close.
Oh my god, so close.
Oh my god.
Tester memory.
This is so hard.
This is so difficult.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, this one's easy.
I'm here.
Wait, did I just spawn in the right place?
Yeah, yeah, you did.
I'm done.
I don't know about you guys.
Okay, this is where I am.
Alright, nice.
We did not get to chill.
Did you use my box?
Why did you take it?
Guys.
Okay.
Stop.
Stop it.
Wait, push the blue off.
Push the blue off.
Okay.
Why did you grab me?
Why did you?
You can take anybody's box.
Yeah, you can just grab people's fucking box.
You can just grab the- Someone sabotaged me.
I know what you guys brought us.
Mia!
Why did you punch me?
That's it.
If my box can't be where a lot of nobody's box can be Okay.
Oh, fuck.
That's so fucked.
Okay.
This is where I am.
Oh, fuck.
I'm right here.
Okay.
This is where I am.
Where the fuck am I?
Okay.
Oh, it's over.
Oh, no, please.
I did my box.
Guys.
Don't worry, Yellow.
I'm gonna do us a solid.
Okay.
Now, Yellow, you just have to come back here and stand behind the- Stop sucking me!
Please!
Get some of this out of here!
Rin, I don't think you're supposed to stay in there, Rin.
I don't think you're supposed to be there, Rin!
I don't think this box is supposed to be- I don't think this box is supposed to be- What the fuck?
Wait, this might be okay.
This might be it.
There's no way.
No, the box is out of position.
No, this might be okay.
This might be okay.
Rest.
No!
The box!
I just wanna be happy.
No, not the box.
Okay.
The box!
I nearly- I was nearly clicking it, too!
My box needs to be down.
Um...
Okay.
I'm here.
This is all I am.
I'm gonna sabotage.
Box, stay here.
Box, stay there.
Nice box.
Hi!
Thanks.
Thanks, slime.
You want it?
Push it over.
There you go.
There's your box.
Oh, wow!
Thank you!
Yay!
Wow, this has been the most teamwork I've ever seen.
Hold on!
Wait, wait.
What are we supposed to walk out of that table?
What are we doing here, bros?
Wait, is it here?
I don't know!
I don't know.
Why are you taking it?
I just put it there because I- No!
I trusted you, Juniper!
I didn't know what I was supposed to do!
I thought you were doing something.
I was like, what?
That's not my color!
I don't know!
You're freaking out!
I thought you needed the box!
I thought you needed it!
You're freaking out!
Okay, click on your spot.
Click on...
Oh no!
I wasn't paying attention!
It's over.
It's over with me.
Can you just walk to me?
Can you just walk to the right, Toki?
I'm walking to the right.
I can't move!
Guys!
I can't even...
I can't!
Have the people with boxes move first.
How about that?
Someone vacuumed me right at the end.
Someone let me out the way.
Guys, okay.
People with boxes, do your part and then we'll wait, okay?
Everybody with a box moves.
Box got to go down here.
Box people move first.
Don't and if you don't have a box don't touch the other people's boxes
I look like I'm blocking.
I'm feeling your face here.
You had
to go in the corner!
What do you mean I wasn't there?
I was locked the fuck in!
Why you now?
Wow, that was a good guess.
I almost got it though.
How did you figure that out, Snuffy?
Okay, I'm locked in.
I'm locked in.
I can't keep doing this.
Okay, this is it.
This is it.
Okay, people with boxes go first.
People with boxes go first.
Okay, I have a box.
I'm six.
Please let me go first.
I'm going to the left.
Okay, I'm going to stay here until ten seconds left.
Please be kind.
I'm going to the left.
Please, everybody, make way.
Make way.
Guys, I feel like some people without boxes went up, guys.
Oh, my bad.
Excuse me.
Okay.
Guys, I'm perfect now.
Everything about my position and my box is perfect.
Do not touch it, please.
Okay.
This is awkward.
How do I do this?
Here we go.
I'm here.
Don't touch mine.
It's over.
It's so over.
What do you mean?
What are you guys doing?
Wait, how did the box get up there?
It was so far away.
Wait, the box was at the third level.
It was supposed to be at the bottom.
I didn't get up there.
I didn't even get up there.
It didn't even jump up because it was at the end.
Okay.
People with boxes go first.
Yeah.
Okay.
None of us do anything.
Val, if you need help, let me know.
Okay.
I'm down here with your box.
Well, not with your box.
Boxes go first.
I have a box.
All right.
Hi-yah.
Okay.
Fuck.
Okay, I'm good.
Okay.
Excuse me.
Are you okay over there with the box, people?
Here we go.
My box is good.
I'm heading over to my spot now.
I'm heading...
Okay.
No, stop.
Please don't move my box.
Please move my box.
Why is it...
Why is it those two again?
Why?
Oh,
yeah, yeah.
Don't do that.
Oh, I got it.
There you go.
Wow.
You got your box.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
Oh, I got it.
Give me your box.
Okay.
You can hold your box.
You can hold your box and jump up to the bottom floor.
My jump.
It doesn't go away.
I'm going to die.
Okay.
My box is almost in the same position, okay?
Just don't move my box!
Dude, I have to go south!
Okay, where am I?
Okay, I'm not there.
Alright, it's fine.
Val doesn't have to move a box.
And it's on the third floor.
It's not on the third floor.
Okay.
Just make sure Red gets out of the ring.
Okay, I'm gonna head over now.
No, no, no!
Don't move it!
Okay!
Watch out!
I'm here!
Okay, leave it there!
Okay!
Wait, I need to be in between!
Thank you!
No!
There you go!
Holy shit!
Oh, is this it?
Is this it?
It's so close, but I don't think it's close enough, Rose!
I don't think it's close enough!
I think it is!
Are we free?
Oh, I'm gonna throw up!
Oh, I'm good!
I'm good!
This is it!
Yay!
Let's go!
Am I crying in your arms right now?
Oh my god!
This is so funny!
Wait, hold on!
Shit!
Wait, okay, I was gonna be like that!
It's so fun to be sad!
Get out!
Rose, please!
Oh my god!
Guys, it's...
It hasn't even been two hours!
It's almost two hours and we completed three worlds out of thirteen!
That's good!
I agree!
Who said we don't have a stream until we finish?
We should open an academy!
Okay, what is this?
What the fuck is this?
Stack?
Don't touch the top!
Don't touch the squiggly lines!
Oh, I think it's gonna go down!
That's a trick!
There's a trick!
I'm sorry!
Oh...
Time to take the easy way out!
How do we...?
I think you have to do it with as few people as possible.
So that there's only one layer maybe?
I think only four people could fit.
Yes.
I mean, it's still past the key though.
I assume hopefully that the blocks will come back up when the washing is done.
Yeah, I think there's like one person.
You have to be alive.
It's just a population check.
A population check?
Okay, we need one more over there.
I will make the sacrifice.
You got this.
Go four.
Four, four, four!
Line, line, line, line!
Okay, there, there, there.
Okay.
If this is wrong, then I guess you will die, which sucks.
There's no way.
I'll miss you.
I'll miss you!
I know, I know, I know, because it can't kill you so you like stand in between.
We stand in between the thing that goes down.
We stand in between the doors.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, we stand in between the doors.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, so we need like...
So I'll...
We need standers.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, we need people to block the door here.
The game was only made for four players.
Okay, so we need one more, we need one more.
We need one more to be up here.
Yeah, we need another key.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, we need you to be up here.
Okay, now grab the key and then you guys...
Yeah, yeah, alright.
You need to block the door.
Yeah, there we go, there we go.
Position, position, perfect.
Okay.
Okay, and then...
Oh...
You win this time, Ely!
You get annihilated.
Oh, thanks for that!
If you live in music, you messed up.
Yeah, that's true.
Okay, everybody up, everybody up.
I'll be at the last door, I'll be at the last door.
No, no, no, no.
I can time this better.
No, it's okay.
Alright, you be at the last door.
I don't want the pressure.
Sorry.
Hi, Snuffy.
Hi, meow.
Okay, everybody, meow, meow.
Okay, we must start slightly.
There we go, there we go.
Okay.
You scooch, you scooch.
There we go.
Okay, okay, okay.
Keep scooching, keep scooching.
Let's go.
I forgot what color I was.
How did you clean this color?
You forgot.
We need a little bit of excitement.
A little bit of suspense.
Oh, not you again.
Wait, what's this?
He's not attached to anything.
In fairness, I think this is the first time they've shown up.
That's probably gonna fall off.
Is he gonna, like, start pinballing?
He turned into Sonic the Hedgehog.
Wait, I think we can stack it.
I think we should stack.
Stack to four?
Yeah, and then one goes right and the other goes left?
Maybe?
Or, like, we all go right.
It's moving around like a pinball.
Yeah, it goes crazy.
Or we can all stack it up.
We can all stack it up.
Wait, what's this over here?
Pick the key!
Go, go, go!
Oh, what the fuck?
Okay, so, they can't go past that.
Which is good.
They go right first.
So, maybe, like...
Oh, I see, I see.
Let's see.
One person goes up and gets the key.
Wait, actually, no.
Because then it goes back to us.
Can we see what the box does first?
Yeah, yeah.
No, no, no, don't touch it, don't touch it.
Okay, what if we just push the box?
We'll push it, yeah.
Okay.
Alright,
we pushed the box.
Nobody jump, guys.
I know it's very tempting.
Okay, we need you to push the box.
No, that's not gonna help.
Okay, okay.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
Okay.
And then we push the sword away from the door.
Wait, we have one here, too.
And this one is for the other one that comes down.
Oh, okay.
Oh, I see.
Push it this way.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Push it closer to us.
Here, hold on.
Push it like...
I don't know where the other saw a spawn.
Okay, one of you guys get it then.
One of you guys get the key.
Wait, wait, wait.
We can push it towards the key.
Oh, yeah, okay.
Oh, I see.
It's to block the blades.
Don't jump, guys.
Don't jump.
There's no key.
It's over there.
Guys, we have to get that one block.
We still have to get that one block, guys.
Okay, nice.
Nice.
Alright, I am gonna push to the left.
I'm pushing.
Pass where the key is, I think, right?
I don't know.
Okay, here.
Alright.
Yeah, pass through the key.
No, no, no.
We want it here.
Yeah, yeah.
Grab the key.
It'll bounce on the block and then we get it to safety.
Nice, okay.
No, keep pushing it.
Keep pushing it.
And it can't go past the block, right?
Oh, my God.
We're so smart, guys.
Let's go.
Okay, let's go.
Keep pushing.
We can still keep technically.
Yeah, yeah.
Alright, pass the key.
Oh, oh, oh.
Alright, here's the hardest part of the game.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yay.
We did it.
We're victorious.
Wow, World 3?
Alright, here we go.
This is so easy.
Okay, we gotta stack.
We gotta stack.
And not get hit.
Okay, I got hit.
I didn't even see where I spawned first.
This is so fast.
What the heck?
If we don't move, does it start?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Are you sure?
Oh, wait.
Don't move, guys.
Don't touch your keyboard.
We'll see.
Yup, it does.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
We just gotta dodge all of them.
Okay, I got it.
Okay, so it falls.
It keeps falling.
What the heck?
Okay, so memorize how it falls.
Okay.
I'm being attacked by someone.
The third one is something.
Yeah, this is messed up.
Oh, yo.
Okay, we almost figured it out.
We almost figured it out.
We also killed three people.
I need to jump through the key.
Oh my god, timing sucks.
We can get the key afterwards by stacking.
Yeah, yeah, I don't think we have to.
Oh, I'm fine.
We should dodge it.
I know where I have to go.
You guys gotta figure out where you have to land that was the safest.
Ouch.
Fine.
I just have to move like a little.
Oh, whoops.
Ouch.
I just have to move a little bit.
Oh, you're dead.
Oh, never mind.
Kind of maybe.
Okay.
Oh, yo, yo, yo, yo.
Okay, it was just me so I didn't fuck it up.
You were so close.
Hmm.
Oh.
I gotta like jump and then hang really far to the left, I guess?
Or can I jump over?
Alright, I'm fine here.
Do you want to be the one to be on the bottom or do you want me?
This is good.
Okay, you got it.
Okay, we can't fuck this up.
We can't fuck this up, guys.
Yes, we can.
No, we cannot.
I can't move.
We will issue that kind of challenge.
Okay.
There we go.
We can't fuck this up.
No, be careful.
Don't jump.
I'm not moving until you're inside.
Until you're in there.
We actually did that surprisingly very quickly than I expected.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, this might be our last one.
So, let's pray.
Let's all just pray.
Is it because you said that?
For me!
It's 1 AM.
I'm not meant to be here.
We spawned in differently.
Okay.
One at a time.
This has to be one at a time here.
Very carefully, yes.
Only one person can go through per line.
Well, not... Okay.
I could fall through.
I thought I could fall through.
No.
All right.
All the people at the far end can just run off.
Yeah.
And then...
You guys can just run.
Oh, you can stop.
I think you have to wait until we're off of it before you go forward.
Yeah, yeah.
Because you have to do like...
I'll go get the key here.
Okay.
You guys can go off with the next one.
All right.
And then you wait.
Oh, we go?
And then now you go.
It's a little bit delicate.
It's very delicate.
All right.
Okay.
I'll get the key, baby.
I don't know actually.
I'm scared.
Ba-da-da-da-da-da-da.
Ba-da-da-da-da-da.
Okay, Bao.
We gotta move forward, Bao.
We're trapped here.
Okay.
It was a lie.
It's okay.
We can do this.
I'll get the key.
You nestled in my dent and I betrayed you.
I'm sorry.
Oh, fuck, bitch.
Did you jump?
I'm so excited.
Okay.
We're so happy.
Sorry.
My turn.
One person get the key, go unlock the door.
Okay.
Here I'll go.
I swear my brain is fucking slurry right now.
I trust Bao.
Oh, no.
She didn't even finish the sentence yet.
Okay.
Ba-da-da-da-da-da.
One person get the key.
I'm so happy now.
All right.
Here we go.
Cut.
That was all me, Jamie.
We can stack, guys.
You don't have to do it by two, guys.
You guys can stack over there.
I'm just not gonna move.
All right.
Here we go.
Oh, my God.
Whoa, whoa.
Okay.
All right.
We can stack.
I got the key.
Wait, but... wait, but...
No one's got the key.
Not anymore, man.
Not anymore.
It might be safer to just go through individually.
Okay.
No, because that's too much risk.
I would be so sad.
That's like five times more.
Yeah.
That's too much.
Okay.
All right.
Let's have designated...
Yeah.
Designated bottoms.
I haven't died yet to the lines.
Ooh, that disqualifies pretty much everybody, I think.
I've never died.
Okay.
All right.
You can't be a top.
I nominate Lime to be one of the designated bottoms.
All right.
Everybody that's not cannot be a bottom anymore.
All right, girls.
All right.
Stack time.
Okay.
Snoopy, I think we can fit one more if you...
Oh.
Okay.
All right.
Here we go.
We can remake the bottom.
We can remake it.
I don't know if...
Okay, Rin.
Let's see you...
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Are we giving up their bow?
Are you okay?
For so long, I forgot what...
What happened.
How are we gonna get through the lasers at the end?
What the fuck?
How did you die?
You know what?
I'm gonna stop.
I apologize.
Are you okay?
I'll be waiting for four more apologies from every single one of you on my desk by next Monday.
Okay.
I get one.
Everybody gets one.
That was my one.
I literally... That was the first time!
Shut up!
That was literally my first time!
Okay.
I don't wanna get the key anymore.
Someone else can.
Let's go.
I got this.
Okay.
Yeah.
I feel like our tanks are leaning a little bit too far to the right.
All right.
Yeah, this is better.
This is better.
All right.
You guys stack up.
They don't even look like cat in lockdown.
Just like skulls.
All right.
You guys ready?
We're talking to you, Doki.
I love you!
All right.
Okay.
Are we really?
Guys.
I've had a revelation.
Here.
Get on me.
The taller the towers are, the easier it is to align them with the green cubes.
Yes.
Exactly.
This is like rescuing me.
It's crispy.
Here we go.
Everybody's bringing everything up.
Wait, Bal can you inch over so that your ink can tear?
Yes.
All right.
Here we go.
Why doesn't it keep.
If it touches it.
Ugh, that is scary.
Oh, my God.
It was such a small margin.
We had to be perfectly lined up.
Yeah, that's what I was... yeah, yeah, yeah.
Be like so perfect, like make sure that your bottom and my bottom are aligned.
Alright, here we go.
You can line them up with like the feet and the ears.
Alright, you guys go forward first just in case we do all that and then we die.
I don't appreciate how that tower is leaning.
Okay.
Just call your tower bad, Avalee.
Well, sometimes it's like you're going to live with it.
I realized it as I said it.
Alright, here you go.
Oh my god.
I'm watching you.
Orange, get it together, orange.
Yeah, I want to join in.
Oh my god.
I believe.
Okay, okay.
Jump on Snuffy.
Oh, I don't think she's going to get on.
It's all on her.
She doesn't want me to bottom anymore.
Get it!
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
I like how Juniper is just watching her.
Oh, there it is.
I'm watching.
If she dies, please, please, I'll remember her face.
The last... you just know it.
You can't fuck that up.
Okay, Juniper, our girl.
End of challenge.
Get through the goal.
Oh my god.
I'm so proud of you.
I'm so proud of all of you.
With love and envy.
We did it.
We completed the goal for team building exercise.
Oh my god.
We did it.
You guys, I was shrimping so hard over my keyboard.
Prominent spinal damage from this one.
What special park?
Yeah, let's do this.
This should be our last one.
It says special park.
What makes it so special?
One level.
Okay.
What makes it so special?
Oh, one.
It's...
Oh my god.
It's squid game.
That's why it's so special.
Alright.
Okay.
There's one button that's dead.
The pressure.
Oh my god.
Oh, I didn't...
I won.
Oh.
Go ahead.
Of course it was you two.
We have to just get it right.
Oh.
Let's do it again.
Just get it right.
That's crazy.
How bad can it be?
What if you just won?
We'll be the last person to...
This is an evil game.
Oh, hey guys.
We're doing really well.
Now this is what I call Pico Park 2.
Oh no.
Please.
There's just three of us.
Oh my god.
No pressure.
There's just three of us.
It's like a 50-50 chance.
You win these.
There's like so many buttons.
It's okay.
So many buttons.
Alright.
Yeah, yeah.
Sophie, I put you in you.
No, that's our...
Okay.
No.
You got this.
I love my family.
It's that one.
Okay.
Or would it be that?
Or would it be this?
Oh, thank god.
Thank god.
Be nice
to us.
We thought Pico Park was going to take mercy on us, did ya?
Oh, that's interesting.
No way.
There's no way.
I saw the fucking buttons weren't pressed right before Min hit one and I was like they wouldn't.
They fucking didn't.
That's actually crazy.
I was like so happy.
I was like hopping along.
You were so happy you started glowing and I was like no.
No!
Bless you.
Well, there's no way Min hits the first one.
Yeah, there's no way.
Right, right, right.
She's this one.
This one.
Oh.
Pick this one.
This one's okay.
That one's okay.
You think so?
Alright, I'm gonna pick this one.
On your advice.
Yeah.
It was a one out of ten chance.
Wow, the orangey dodge.
This one's safe.
I swear.
See?
I told you.
Oh my god.
Good vibes on this one.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm not fucking around.
I'm just going for the one nearest to the door.
If I can get down, please.
Okay, I wanna get the close.
I wanna hear this fucking song in my sleep.
There we go.
Are you having fun yet?
Three left.
Oh no, it's just, oh no.
She's like, let's go gambling.
Aw, dang it.
Oh no.
I'm scared.
Why am I last?
No pressure or anything.
The last one.
Alright.
Oh, good one.
Maybe there's no one nearest the door.
Maybe.
Okay, yeah.
I'll go for this one.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So we can all walk there.
So we all know it's safe.
Dude, the pause.
The pause they did.
Okay, okay, okay.
Look how we all waited.
Alright.
We did it.
No more.
Oh my god.
I'm so proud of us.
See, we can.
This game doesn't stop until we do all 13 levels.
You're a psycho.
A psycho.
You're sick in the head.
Some of us have families, okay?
Imagine we had to listen to that soundtrack for two more hours.
Imagine we had to do that.
Even more than two hours, I think.
I came already this far.
We might as well just finish the game.
I can keep going too.
Alright.
Can we actually finish this game with seven of us?
I think we can.
I thought we were meant to be friends.
Well, we're not quitters.
Endurance scream.
Unfortunately for 10% of gamblers, it is their bedtime now, so...
Good night, gamblers.
Good night.
Good night, old man.
Kids these days, honestly.
God.
Alright.
Are we actually completing this game?
I'm doubting.
Wait, are we actually?
Are we actually?
We can do it another day, right?
You know, for the sake of our brains, right?
Alright, Rin.
If we're gonna do another day, you have to be there till the very end.
Okay.
You have to...
Oh my god.
John Pico will come to your house.
Yeah.
Send us to five of your friends.
Okay.
We will schedule Pico Park 2 and we're going...
Pico Park 2.
And we have to do it until we finish.
We got clear entire schedule just for this game.
The entire day.
Entire day.
Just to finish this game.
No food.
Tower up.
We only get rewarded until we beat it.
We need a 15 minute bathroom break.
You gotta hold it until we beat it.
You got one ration, one bathroom break.
The only pee you can have is Pico Park 2.
Wow.
If you didn't get a gamer bottle, you're not committed.
Everyone ship a special gamer chair.
Yeah.
A special gamer chair just for Pico Park.
You get one meal and one plastic bottle.
Yeah.
Sit the hell down.
Alright, alright.
You know, normal people play video games for fun.
This is worse than the Marines.
Okay.
Part 2 is going to be an endurance stream.
We are all committed, right?
We all swear no.
We're all into a blood pack until we cannot leave.
We hope you guys have your rabies shot.
I hope we can start a little earlier than 11pm.
If we end, if it takes us 6 hours, it'll take us 6 hours.
But we'll all be here.
If we hate each other by the end of it, then that's just a sacrifice we gotta be willing to make.
A flow of poison is slowly dripping into our veins.
We need to beat it before the time limit.
It's like we're going to make a saw event out of this.
I mean, that's basically Pico Pops.
Alright, GG's everybody.
GG's, I'll see you guys.
I'll see you guys for part 2.
GG's everyone.
GG's.
Bye guys.
Bye.
Oh my god.
I did not...
I didn't think we were going to come back to this game, but I guess we are.
Okay.
That was fun.
That was really fun.
I had a great time playing with the girls again.
I...
It's just the same.
The same one music track.
Two actually.
One with the main menu.
So the same two music tracks.
But huge shout out to the girls.
For... Oh, I'm the only one left.
For wanting to do another collab together.
I had a great time.
You know.
Two hours.
The music hasn't numbed my brain yet.
So I'm pretty sure by part 2 I will be very...
My brain's going to be like...
Liquid.
Oh my gosh.
I can't even form sentences right now.
Holy shit.
Maybe it's already numb.
I can't even!
I can't even form sentences anymore!
Maybe it's already too late.
It's already too late for me.
But it was super fun.
I had a great time.
I hope you guys had a great time with them too.
I'm sorry.
I can't.
My brain's already... Oh, I should turn the game off.
I hate this fucking soundtrack so much.
I...
I hate it!
I hate this soundtrack so fucking much.
I'm going to call it here everybody.
It's just like how I remembered Pico Park.
There's nothing else to say.
It's just how I remembered.
Equally...
Equally as Pico.
That was so much fun, Toki.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I can't believe the hardest part in the entire game was the memorization in the boxes.
The boxes!
The fucking boxes with the memorize where they are.
That was too much.
That was way too much for all of us.
Aphelion, thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you.
This is such a great stream to start my birthday.
Hope you guys are having a good one too.
Thank you.
Thank you for the magenta soup.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Aphelion.
Yeah!
Okay.
I am...
I'm gonna... I don't know when we're gonna have Pico Park Part 2 because I know some people are going to TwitchCon, so we're gonna figure that we might not have it until...
I don't know.
Maybe next week?
I'll see how everybody's schedule is like.
We'll do it earlier because Rin obviously has to sleep, so we'll try and get that... have an earlier stream for it.
Maybe at like 12 or something.
So at least we have like 4 hours of that.
Anyway guys, I'm gonna head off now.
As always, everybody stay hydrated, posture check, get up and get around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed because you deserve it!
I'll see you guys next time everybody!
Bye guys!
Bye!
You guys enjoyed the foogies!
The little foogie graphics I made for everybody.
I made those because like I assumed that like, you know, like it was easier for everybody to see where... like who's who.
So I hope you guys liked the little foogie graphics that I made for everybody.
Anyway, bye for real!
Bye!